hey guys first of all thank you for
clicking you're about to watch a new
video or another video on YouTube and
before you do - 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 31 if you
are getting value out of my youtube
videos what I'm doing in my text
community is bonkers it's instant it's
access its exclusive and it's just been
a lot of fun and I've just enjoyed
texting back and forth with a lot of you
- 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 I'm sure they're
editing something team I know how you do
it please join my texting community and
now enjoy this YouTube video hey guys
just cuz AJ's here so you don't really
have to do anything AJ but you say hello
AJ who runs famous sports app so you
guys know AJ is well a lot of you don't
you nonetheless something I want to do
more of is make some video content that
goes a little bit deeper into the
insights of things that don't get shown
so I want to make this videos a little
state of the union of Baner sports some
content of different meetings and
different things I can show some updates
some highlights just a fun little Vayner
sports video you'll be seeing more about
this from Sasha from Wine Library from
empathy starting a series of insight
depth looks into the other things that
are going on by putting together a
conglomerate of four months worth of
stuff that leads to one video Wow yeah I
sweat again with it I don't see nobody
in my lane is crying go get it like
so snapback is one of our partners at
Vayner sports they make an amazing piece
of apparel that not only looks good but
also helps athletes recover and warm up
their bodies both hot and cold therapy
and you know they wanted to partner with
us on our client list and one of those
clients in particulars Leonard Williams
obviously Lehner's a tremendously
talented individual has charisma has a
great look and also plays in one of the
biggest markets of the world in New York
City we've taken basically three
modalities that as an athlete you're
accustomed to compression pop therapy
cold therapy simplified those and put it
into a single garment so that you can
have full mobility so while Norma tech
game writing those products are great
products you can't be ambulatory yeah
you're stuck there right so how could we
increase the likelihood that we can get
our athletes to incorporate cold therapy
after training and like right now in
these recovery weeks how do we get guys
sleeping in tights how do we make the
best compression garment in the world
fabricated with the best you know the
best materials that would increase the
likelihood that you'll wear this
compression and you'll just incorporate
either our therapy pods which can be
used for the heater ice or you can use
real eyes all right so when you don't
have access you weren't at the at the
event around the ESPYs I know you were
traveling but we had all the athletes
using real ice to ice after the workout
but the way that the the product works
is you've got a better yeah there's even
better than pockets is that you've got
360 degrees so you don't know where
you're gonna be sore right so somebody
cut blocks you and you have a contusion
on your quad how are you gonna wear ice
on your quad all right saran wrap ace
bandages makes no sense you're not gonna
do it
yeah you have no mobility and then
you've you know the trainer would love
you at home sitting there for 25 minutes
icing but I'm gonna guess you probably
have better things to do than sit for 25
minutes at a time so you can take these
pods they can go anywhere within the
garment when you have it's a compression
garment right so when you have it on
these micro grips have come through the
mesh you can run jump do whatever you
want and ice is not gonna move if you
don't have access to a freezer grab a
ziploc bag real ice in there tuck it
into the product and you can remain
ambulatory throw some basketball shorts
on over it well you put them in the
microwave we're like in the training
room we have a lot of guys a lot of
training staffs that are using these
pods putting in the Hydra ocular so
where they typically have you know the
water they heat that so these will be at
160 degrees coming out of a hydraulic
you later throw them on the muscle areas
that you want to warm up before your
training take them out train in the
garment when you're done throw a nice so
this is the option that house this
season then you got a lot of people
using it yeah so it's actually been
really we you know we're proud to say we
have a hundred percent adoption rate so
once we meet with an athlete introduce
the product to them they incorporated
some guys just for travel right because
this is a properly graduated compression
garment so guys that are on the road
especially baseball sitting on a plane
set yeah you got 70% of your blood is
beneath your heart or you're working
against gravity you've got to get all of
that blood that's pooling back to your
heart to get oxygen delivered and
redistributed to your muscles that's how
you recover but typically people who
don't have compression products that
actually work because a lot of stuff in
the marketplace is not designed to
actually perform for you but yeah so it
is it is a different experience and
obviously you know probably not gonna
try it on today but if he just you know
I'll text you see some other information
if you have specific I'm Woody's bar but
you do like what everybody else does
there's like ice packs which it yeah I
mean like you said we if we do want to
like do a specific
like my father thought that we ended up
like wrapping it all these bandages and
stuff I might limp it to my car to the
side hard to walk with it you know what
I mean so that diplomats lot said and
then we tried a compression type of
thing for traveling one time in college
doorway because we're on flights for so
long yeah tried these compression pants
that USC budget will give with you yeah
it's cool good so they weren't able to
keep on yeah he just did it which just
mean you traveling yeah and you like
that yeah I like that
yeah so it would definitely up like
being able to travel since I'm gonna be
sitting there for so long anyways you
know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Panthers its Kurtis Samuels
Daniel with the fame
city touchdown
[Music]
[Applause]
horse fumble it was recovered by Jalen
reeves-maybin so back-to-back weeks as
you noted big plays by Agnew one
negative with Sookie Smith is one of our
clients he plays fullback for the
Atlanta Falcons and he's somebody who I
just loved riffing with he always has
ideas and one idea in particular we were
really excited to bring to life and help
Keith see his vision through and you
know what I'm particularly happy about
with what Keith has done here it's just
done so well because of how much he
cares how authentic it is to him and I
all he's also gotten other fullbacks
involved I'm going into my third year
the league I was taking it very serious
so I changed the way I was training and
where I put my energy I was focusing
everything it was on football perfecting
my craft so I went back to the basics as
far as training I was focused on balance
stability core training everything like
that instead of lifting heavy as far as
like mental and like knowledge for the
game I started meeting with my coach
more going over plays been extra time
just showing how how committed I really
was and I was ready for for that
opportunity I had in front of me so
going into the first day of camp I'm
excited
one-on-ones didn't didn't have any team
figures or anything ended up getting the
hurt and it was just very very
disappointing and I just didn't
understand why at the time come to find
out it was a blessing in disguise
gave me more time to really focus on
what I wanted to do outside of football
as far as starting a athletic apparel
line and
Jim my boy Rodney so the name of the
brand is rectified this is our logo we
went to LA and we met with a lot of
manufacturers and a lot of people that
can help us with marketing and building
out our website and just doing the whole
thing so that's what I've been working
on now and after this we're also
planning on opening the gym called
rectified Fitness so it's a little six
month period I'm taking my time and
energy and putting it elsewhere
instead of being depressed and moping
around and not using my time wisely so
that's something I'll just encourage
people to do if they have to face
adversity and that's what Manor Sports
is all about that's something that Gary
and AJ preach a lot it's just the
athletes being successful off the field
as well and using their platform to be
marketable and take advantage of being
in NFL and using your platform to the
best of your ability so SBS is kind of
like the Grammys or Oscars for sports
it's in July every year and it's just a
great opportunity for us to get our guys
together in LA I just have a really good
time you know maybe sometimes clients
haven't met yet and you know we always
have a good time out there just throw
one of our own parties it's just a rare
opportunity before training camp and a
great blend of entrepreneurs Hollywood
music and sports when I hear the
question what's next the reality is it's
a framework of being ready to move on
something tomorrow if that email comes
in or that dinner happens and it seems
right so I think of myself far more as a
counter-puncher
or a halftime adjustments head coach
than the one that works all week or
plans the I've won a business objective
to buy the New York Jets when I consume
information and opportunities if I feel
like that can advance it whether its
financial like a big investment or
starting a company or whether they're
just optically like the top steel is a
money loser for what I'm getting from
tops but it continues to penetrate me
into the sports consciousness which
gives me leverage in the long term so
some of its brand some of its dollars
but what's next is the continuation of a
framework that allows me to respond
quickly to an opportunity that I think
is viable
[Music]